Do you know where you're going to do this? Do you know where you're going to ask the question?
你知道你要去哪里做这件事吗？你知道你要去哪里问那个问题吗？
Yeah. Yeah, I know where and when.
是的。我知道地点和时间。
Where is it going to be? What can you say about that?
在哪里？能透露一下吗？
At her home, next week.
在她家，下周。
Some answer. You're going in a week. Oh my God. So are you freaking out?
真有你的。你下周就要去了。天哪。那你现在慌吗？
I'm a little excited.
我有点兴奋。
This man is 76. I'm not going to say his name here on the radio, because he's hoping that the woman that he wants to marry is not going to get tipped off by some radio or podcast listener that he's about to ask her. And he doesn't know what she's going to say. He doesn't know. Which is not usually how that goes down, right? Usually, you ask somebody to marry you, you kind of know. He's totally shooting in the dark, anxious about what she's going to say. And this is somebody who he's had feelings about for a long time.
这位男士今年76岁。我不会在广播里说出他的名字，因为他希望他想娶的那位女性，不会因为电台或播客的听众而提前得知他要向她求婚。而且他不知道她会怎么回答。他不知道。通常事情不会这样发展，对吧？通常如果你向某人求婚，你心里多少有点底。他完全是在盲目地尝试，对于她会说什么感到焦虑。而这正是他多年来一直心心念念的那个人。
I met this girl at a time when I was 17, she was 16. She was very popular. She was one of, you might say, the queens in high school, right?
我在17岁的时候遇见了这个女孩，她当时16岁。她当时非常受欢迎。你可以说她是高中里的“女王”之一，对吧？
But nice, he says, really nice.
但他说，她人很好，真的很好。
And I didn't have all the confidence and courage that I needed at the time. And I just felt like I don't I don't measure up. I mean, she can pick any superstar or whatever. I was a fairly good athlete, but I wasn't a superstar and whatever and stuff like that.
当时我没有所需的信心和勇气。我觉得自己配不上她。我是说，她可以挑选任何超级明星之类的。我当时是个还不错的运动员，但我不是什么超级明星。
All right. So you didn't do everything you could.
好吧。所以你没有尽你所能去争取。
No, I didn't try. I just played like, well, hey, we're just friends. And then, when it was time to go to the Navy, I just left, took the coward's way out.
是的，我没有尝试。我只是假装“嘿，我们只是朋友”。后来，到了去海军服役的时候，我就离开了，选择了逃避。
But that experience changed him, he says. When he met his wife, he totally went for it. Didn't want to make the same mistake again. He and his wife were together for nearly 47 years, had children, who are now grown. And when his wife died eight years ago, after some time passed, he checked in with this woman from high school. Well, her husband had died. And so this man started flying to the other side of the country to visit her, where she lives now. He stays in the guest room at her house.
但他表示，那段经历改变了他。当他遇见妻子时，他全力以赴。他不想再犯同样的错误。他和妻子在一起近47年，有了孩子，现在都长大了。八年前他妻子去世后，过了一段时间，他联系了那位高中时的女生。嗯，她的丈夫也去世了。于是这位男士开始飞往大洋彼岸去看望她，也就是她现在居住的地方。他住在她家的客房里。
So the visits there, I would visit her for a week or so, and we hung out everyday, and we just did natural things. And we just went places and what have you. But there was really no intimacy involved, realistically. We were just hanging out, and I believe she was having a good time. I was having a good time. You know?
我去那里待过一周左右，我们每天都在一起，做些自然而然的事情。我们到处走走什么的。但实际上并没有任何亲密关系。我们只是在一起待着，我相信她玩得很开心，我也很开心。你懂吗？
But you guys didn't kiss?
但你们没接吻吗？
Well, maybe only once or twice over those years and what have you. And every time we met, it was a friendly kiss on the side of the face, but it wasn't anything like a passionate, real kiss. And that happened only once, along the way, once or twice along the way.
嗯，这些年里可能只有一两次。每次见面，都只是脸颊上的友好一吻，不是那种充满激情的吻。而且那也只发生过一两次。
Now, you must have been testing the waters and saying things to figure out where she felt and what her feelings were, right?
你当时肯定是在试探，说些话来摸清她的心意和感觉吧，对吗？
I was trying very hard to find that out along the way, Ira. And I was getting some mixed signals. I didn't-- I had a sense on the one hand, when it was all over--
艾拉，我一直很努力地想搞清楚这一点。但我得到了一些模棱两可的信号。我不知道……一方面，当一切结束时，我有一种感觉——
OK, those mixed signals, she'd hold his hand all the time. She never hesitated when he would call her and ask to schedule another week-long visit. But at the same time, she seemed very encouraging about him going out with other people, like weirdly encouraging. And she did not seem interested in discussing her feelings towards him.
好的，那些模棱两可的信号，她会一直牵着他的手。当他打电话要求安排下一次为期一周的探访时，她从不犹豫。但与此同时，她似乎很鼓励他和别人约会，甚至到了奇怪的地步。而且她似乎对讨论她对他的感情毫无兴趣。
It seemed like any time a question or anything came up that related towards that or went in that direction, she tended to slide away from it a little bit.
似乎每当涉及到这方面的问题或话题时，她往往会稍微回避一下。
That does not sound good to me.
这听起来可不太妙。
That didn't sound good to me either. My feeling was that she didn't want you to ask this question. She doesn't want to have to give you that answer.
对我来说也不妙。我的感觉是，她不想让你问这个问题。她不想被迫给你那个答案。
Did you tell her you love her?
你告诉她你爱她了吗？
Yes, I did.
是的，我说了。
Has she ever said I love you back?
她有没有回应过“我也爱你”？
No, no.
没有，没有。
Well, is it possible she just wants to be friends?
嗯，有没有可能她只是想做朋友？
Very good possibility.
很有可能。
OK, ladies and gentlemen, I know what you're thinking. This does not sound promising at all. And, oh my God, what love struck creatures we all are, wandering around this earth, right? Here is a 76-year-old man, a father, a grandfather with the same logic defying feelings dominating him that a teenager has. He told me that back in July after years of wondering with this woman, OK, are we always just going to be friends? Is this ever going to be more than that, he finally told her, OK, look, we're going on a date. We're going on a date. It's going to be a real date. Are you up to have a real date with me? And she said yes.
好的，女士们先生们，我知道你们在想什么。这听起来一点也不乐观。天哪，我们都是多么为情所困的生物，在这地球上游荡，对吧？这是一位76岁的老人，一位父亲，一位祖父，有着和十几岁少年一样违背理性的情感。他告诉我，在七月经历多年的纠结后——我们是不是只能做朋友？这能有进一步发展吗？——他终于告诉她：“听着，我们要去约会。我们要去约会了。这是一次真正的约会。你愿意和我进行一次真正的约会吗？”她说愿意。
So how'd that go?
那进展如何？
It went well, but it didn't go any differently than all the other dates we went on.
进行得很顺利，但和我们之前所有的约会没什么不同。
So nothing really changed?
所以其实什么都没变？
No. So realistically, if I want to be just honest with you and-- I don't know where this can go, what have you, but my feeling is that either she truly wants me to move on, or she's waiting for me to ask this question. Will you marry me? That's really where I am. And I don't know which one is true.
是的。所以现实地讲，如果我要对你诚实……我不知道这能发展到什么地步，但我感觉，要么她真的希望我向前看，要么她是在等我问那个问题：你愿意嫁给我吗？这就是我现在的处境。我不知道哪一个是真的。
But you know people, if somebody is interested, they let you know. If a lady is interested, she figures out a way to let you know, right?
但你知道的，如果一个人有兴趣，他们会让你知道的。如果一位女士有兴趣，她会想办法让你知道的，对吧？
Yeah. Some people might say, well, hey, she lets you stay at her house. I mean, you stay there all week.
是的。有些人可能会说，嘿，她让你住在她家。我是说，你整周都待在那里。
Oh man, you are stuck on this lady. Oh my god.
天哪，你真的陷进去了。天哪。
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑]
Well, let's put it this way. That may be the case, but it doesn't change anything that I just want to know that, hey, I did everything I could. And that's what I didn't do first time. That's what I didn't do the first time.
好吧，换个说法。也许是这样，但这改变不了什么，我只是想知道，我确实尽我所能了。这就是我第一次没做到的事。第一次时我没做到。
You know, what strikes me is that this is just very inconvenient for you, that you like her so much.
你知道，让我吃惊的是，你这么喜欢她，这对你来说太不方便了。
That I like her so much? That that's inconvenient?
我太喜欢她了？这不方便？
Yeah, yeah, that you're having these feelings, that you're stuck on this lady, it seems like you're in the grip of this thing. You don't even have  a choice. It defies all good sense. You know all the signs pointing against it. And yet-- and yet you feel like you have no choice. You have to ask this question.
是的，你有这些感情，你陷在这个女人身上，看起来你完全被它掌控了。你甚至没得选择。这完全违背了理智。你知道所有迹象都指向不行。然而，你还是觉得没得选择。你必须问这个问题。
Oh, I do have to. In truth, I understand that. I do have to ask the question. My heart says resolve it. You know, just resolve it. And if her heart doesn't want it, then I don't want it with her. You know?
噢，我确实必须问。老实说，我明白这一点。我必须问这个问题。我的心说去解决它吧。你知道，解决了它。如果她的心不想要，那我就不会和她在一起了。你懂吗？
Honestly, over the course of this conversation, I went from thinking that it was a terrible idea for him to ask this woman to marry him next week, to thinking he should totally do it. He totally convinced me that he needed to hear yes or no once and for all. And maybe he was going to get what he wanted, or maybe he was going to be set free, but either one of those was going to be better than just floating around her like he's been, wanting this thing to happen.
老实说，在这次对话的过程中，我对他的建议从“下周向这个女人求婚是个糟糕的主意”，转变为“他绝对应该这样做”。他完全说服了我，他需要一次性听到是或否。也许他会得到他想要的，或者也许他会被解脱，但这两种结果都比像现在这样漂浮在她身边、渴望着事情发生要好。
And then, OK, we talked the next day on the phone. And I learned that a weird thing happened in that conversation that he and I had had the day before, which is we switched positions. He had completely convinced me that he should ask her, but I had completely convinced him that he should not, because she wasn't showing enough signs that she loves him, because it seemed doomed on its face.
然后，第二天我们在电话里谈了话。我了解到在我们前一天的谈话中发生了一件奇怪的事，那就是我们交换了立场。他完全说服了我他应该求婚，但我完全说服了他他不该求婚，因为她没表现出足够的爱意，而且这看起来注定会失败。
So the next day, Tuesday, this week, we got on the phone and he told me his new very pragmatic, very sober plan. He's not going to ask her to marry him next week. He's just going to tell her his feelings, and see if she's open to being in a real, actual, committed relationship.
所以第二天，这周二，我们通了电话，他告诉了我他新的、非常务实、非常冷静的计划。他下周不会向她求婚。他只会告诉她他的感受，看看她是否愿意建立一段真正、实际、有承诺的关系。
This opens the door to get started with a relationship. I'm not really saying that she would want to go there, but if she does, then the question would be, well, where do we go from there?
这开启了建立关系的大门。我并不是说她一定愿意往那方面发展，但如果她愿意，那么问题就是，我们接下来该怎么办？
So he flies to his fate this weekend. He's asking her Wednesday, he thinks. "The heart wants what it wants." Emily Dickinson wrote that. Though depending on how old you are, you might associate it with Woody Allen or Selena Gomez. Today on our program, people who get stuck on somebody, whether that's a good idea or not, whether they want to or not, people who get stuck, even when the signs are not looking so very good for them at all.
所以他这个周末要去面对他的命运。他认为他会在周三问她。“心之所向。”艾米莉·狄金森写过这句话。尽管根据你的年龄，你可能会把它和伍迪·艾伦或赛琳娜·戈麦斯联系在一起。今天在我们的节目中，讲述那些陷于某人而无法自拔的人，无论这是否是个好主意，无论他们是否愿意。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
来自WBEZ芝加哥，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act 1, Jesse's Girl. So here's a great example of the heart wanting what it wants against all reason. It's the story of a con that lasted for over two decades. And when the con was discovered, there was a trial. And incredibly, some of the people who had been conned testified on behalf of the man who scammed them. They defended the con in court. Which is to say, that even after the con was over and the truth was revealed, people still bought into it. NPR's social science correspondent, Shankar Vedantam was so curious about why and talked to some of the victims, including a man who says he got a lot out of being conned. Here's Shankar.
第一幕，杰西的女孩。这是一个心之所向、违背一切理性的绝佳例子。这是一个持续了二十多年的骗局的故事。当骗局被发现时，进行了审判。令人难以置信的是，一些被骗的人竟然出庭为那个欺骗他们的人辩护。他们在法庭上为这个骗局辩护。也就是说，即使在骗局结束后，真相大白，人们仍然愿意相信它。NPR的社会科学记者尚卡尔·维丹坦对此感到非常好奇，并采访了一些受害者，包括一名声称从被骗中获益良多的男人。请听尚卡尔的报道。
So here's how the con worked. Guys around the country signed up for a pen pal service. It would put them in touch with women they could befriend and correspond with. And then they'd start to receive letters.
骗局是这样运作的。全国各地的男士注册了一项笔友服务。它让他们联系上可以结交和通信的女性。然后他们就会开始收到信件。
They come from Hillsdale, Illinois. Some of them are white, pink, green.
它们来自伊利诺伊州的希尔斯代尔。有些是白色的，有些是粉色的，有些是绿色的。
Jesse is a sweet, soft spoken man with thick, plastic aviator glasses. He started receiving the letters in 1985, when he was in his 30s. Back then, he was overweight. He'd never had a serious girlfriend, always lived with his parents. After his mother died, he spent most of his time taking care of his sick dad and working at his family's restaurant.
杰西是一个温和、说话轻声细语的男人，戴着一副厚重的塑料飞行员眼镜。他从1985年开始收到这些信件，当时他30多岁。那时，他超重，从未有过正式的女朋友，一直和父母住在一起。母亲去世后，他大部分时间都在照顾生病的父亲，并在家族餐馆工作。
Jesse's favorite letters came from a woman named Pamela.
杰西最喜欢的信件来自一个叫帕梅拉的女人。
Yes, I usually took it at the end of the day, when I got them in the mail, went into my room and laid on my bed and just sat there and read them. "Dear Jesse, deep down, you know as well as I do that you could be a lot better off than you are if you only had someone on your side, someone who would help you, encourage you, work with you, and stick with you even when things get bad. What I'm talking about, of course, is a true friend, but that kind of person is hard to find today, isn't it?
是的，我通常在一天结束时收到邮件后，回到房间，躺在床上，坐下来读它们。“亲爱的杰西，你心底很清楚，只要有个人站在你这边，有人能帮助你、鼓励你、与你共事，即使在逆境中也不离不弃，你的日子会好过得多。我所说的当然是一个真正的朋友，但这种人在当今很难找到，不是吗？”
Jesse had never met or talked to Pamela, but he was curious. He wrote back, telling her a little about himself. And Pamela replied again and again. The letters were typed in a girlish font and signed in a blue pen with big loopy letters. In another letter, Pamela wrote, "Just before I sat down to write this letter to you, I was thinking how lucky I am that in this great, big, crazy world I found you. I hope I can be part of your life for a long time, Darling, and I hope, as time goes by, I'll be able to make you happier and happier."
杰西从未见过或谈过帕梅拉，但他很好奇。他回信了，告诉她一些关于自己的事。帕梅拉不断回信。信件是用少女风格的字体打出的，用蓝色钢笔签名，字迹大而圆润。在另一封信中，帕梅拉写道：“在坐下来写这封信之前，我还在想，在这个巨大、疯狂的世界里能找到你，我是多么幸运。我希望我能长期成为你生活的一部分，亲爱的，随着时间的流逝，我希望我能让你越来越快乐。”
This mystery woman seemed to know him. She made Jesse feel understood. She made him feel loved.
这个神秘的女人似乎了解他。她让杰西感到被理解。她让他感到被爱。
You can tell when you meet a person that they're not superficial. This is coming from their heart. Everybody's looking for that perfect love and everything, and this pops up. So I thought, well, could this be something different?
当你见到一个人时，你能看出他们并不肤浅。这是发自内心的。每个人都在寻找完美的爱情，而这突然出现了。所以我心想，嗯，这会不会是某种特别的东西？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
This was Pamela. He was middle aged, balding, and had a small, gray mustache. His real name was Don Lowry.
这就是帕梅拉。他中年，秃顶，留着小灰胡子。他的真名叫唐·洛里。
Was any of it difficult, to come up with these characters? Did the characters bore you? I mean, tell me about it as a writing project.
想出这些角色有困难吗？这些角色让你感到厌倦吗？我是说，跟我说说这个写作项目吧。
No. No, I looked at a photograph of a girl and said what kind of girl is this? Where is she from? What does she like to do? It was fairly easy after a while. The first 20 were a little bit rough, but the next 80 were not hard at all.
不。不，我看着一张女孩的照片，然后问：这是什么样的女孩？她从哪里来？她喜欢做什么？过了一段时间后，这相当容易。前20个稍微有点费劲，但接下来的80个一点也不难。
And you enjoyed making up these characters?
你喜欢编造这些角色吗？
I loved it! Yeah, I loved it. I admit that.
我太喜欢了！是的，我喜欢。我承认这一点。
Don died in 2014, but I met him in 2011, in a rundown house in Butler, Pennsylvania. He was 82. If you have trouble understanding Don's voice, it's because he was a lifelong heavy smoker. The desk in his living room was covered with ash. His sofa smelled of smoke. Don told me he always wanted to be a writer, but his real talent was in being a hustler. He always had a scheme going.
唐于2014年去世，但我于2011年在宾夕法尼亚州巴特勒的一间破败房子里见到了他。他82岁。如果你听不懂唐的声音，那是因为他是个终身的老烟枪。他客厅的桌子上满是烟灰。他的沙发闻起来全是烟味。唐告诉我，他一直想当作家，但他真正的天赋是做个骗子。他总是有各种花招。
In his early 30s, Don visited Mexico and wrote a traveler's guide where he explained how American men could live cheaply there, pick up women, and get by with rudimentary Spanish.
30岁出头时，唐去过墨西哥，写了一本旅游指南，解释美国男人如何在当地低成本生活、搭讪女性，并靠基本的西班牙语过活。
It was called Mexico, Bachelor's Paradise.
书名叫《墨西哥，单身汉的天堂》。
It didn't sell. And then he tried something most writers would never consider. He changed the name of the book's author to a woman's name. Sales skyrocketed, he said. Apparently, lonely American men didn't want tips from a guy. They wanted tips from a girl. Don realized there was a market waiting to be exploited. He rented mailing lists from magazines that catered to single men and started writing letters to them, posing as different women. Men like Jesse were invited to join a club, where in exchange for a small fee, they could receive love letters.
它没卖出去。然后他尝试了一件大多数作家永远不会考虑的事情：他把作者名字改成了女性的名字。他说销量直线上升。显然，孤独的美国男人不想听男人的建议。他们想要女人的建议。唐意识到有一个等待被开发的市场。他租用了面向单身男性的杂志的邮寄名单，开始冒充不同的女性给他们写信。像杰西这样的男人被邀请加入一个俱乐部，只要支付一小笔费用，就可以收到情书。
In a moment of inspiration, Don decided to call the women who wrote the letters angels, Angel Linda, Angel Kristina, Angel Pamela. He purchased stock photos of models and printed catalogs with photos and bios for each angel. Angels came in different flavors. Some were compliant, helpless, and pure. Others were raunchy and sent nude photos of themselves. Most were young and all were eager to please. Dream women for a certain kind of man, dreamed up of course by another man.
在灵感迸发的时刻，唐决定将写信的女性称为“天使”：安吉尔·琳达，安吉尔·克里斯蒂娜，安吉尔·帕梅拉。他购买了模特照片，并印刷了带有每位天使照片和简历的目录。天使有不同的类型。有的顺从、无助、纯洁。有的则淫秽，并寄出自己的裸照。大多数都很年轻，而且都急于讨好。对于某种男人来说，这是梦中情人，当然是由另一个男人编织出来的梦。
In one brochure, Angel Linda Scott is pictured in a one piece swimsuit on her hands and knees. Angel Kristina looks like an idealistic woman. She's shown hugging a tree and holding a flower. I prefer a certain type of man, Kristina says. "He can pick up a handful of dark, rich soil and feel a kind of reverence and joy. But he's awfully hard to find."
在一本宣传册中，安吉尔·琳达·斯科特身穿连体泳衣，四肢着地趴着。安吉尔·克里斯蒂娜看起来像一个理想主义女性。她被拍到抱着一棵树，拿着一朵花。克里斯蒂娜说：“我偏爱某种男人。他能抓起一把深色、肥沃的土壤，感受到某种敬畏和喜悦。但这种人真的很难找。”
Don mailed these brochures to men like Jesse. If a man wrote back, Don began sending letters to him as Angel Kristina or Angel Linda. Don told me he didn't want members who were just looking for sex. He wanted men looking for meaningful relationships, who would be in it for the long haul. He thought this would be better for business and better for the marks.
唐把这些宣传册寄给像杰西这样的男人。如果有人回信，唐就开始以安吉尔·克里斯蒂娜或安吉尔·琳达的身份写信给他。唐告诉我，他不想要只是寻求性关系的会员。他想要寻找有意义的关系、愿意长期投入的男人。他认为这对生意更好，对这些受害者也更好。
A guy, his wife died and he was living alone, he didn't have any friends, that kind of thing. He needed this. He didn't have anything you or anybody else to cheer him up, nobody. Reject. These girls would boost their egos, things like, "Oh, your handwriting is so masculine." Things like that, little things gave the guy a boost. And they loved it.
一个男人，妻子去世了，独自生活，没有朋友。他需要这个。他没有任何人可以安慰他。被拒绝的孤独。这些女孩会提振他们的自尊心，比如，“噢，你的笔迹真有男子气概。”这些小事给这个男人带来了提振。他们爱死这个了。
After a few letters to Jesse, Pamela let him know that the only thing she wanted was a little help. "Darling, I want you to know that I really love writing you every day. It has filled a great need in my life and I know I'd be very sad if I had to stop writing to you and being your friend. I hope you feel the same way about me and my letters to you. I think it's fair and reasonable for me to ask you to help with the expenses of paper, envelopes, postage, photos, and the other things I'll be sending you. If you could send me just $10 a week for my letters, I could continue writing every day as I have been.
给杰西写了几封信后，帕梅拉让他知道她唯一想要的就是一点小小的帮助。“亲爱的，我想让你知道我真的很喜欢每天给你写信。它填补了我生活中巨大的空虚，我知道如果不得不停止给你写信、停止做你的朋友，我会非常难过。我希望你对我也是一样的心情。我认为我请求你帮助支付纸张、信封、邮费、照片以及其他我将寄给你的东西的费用是公平合理的。如果你每周能给我10美元，我就能像现在一样每天写信。”
Jesse was fine with that. He figures he sent in $4,000 or $5,000 between 1985 and '88. It wasn't a big deal to him.
杰西对此没意见。他算了一下，从1985年到1988年间，他汇去了4000到5000美元。对他来说这没什么大不了的。
My business was prospering pretty well. We ran over $100,000 three years in a row, so it was no problem for me to be sending money and stuff. So--
我的生意做得相当不错。我们连续三年销售额超过10万美元，所以汇钱什么的对我来说没问题。所以——
Pamela often sent Jesse stories about the two of them for a little extra money. In one, Pamela and Jesse go on a picnic together. In another, he literally rescues her, as a knight in shining armor. There's one story that has them both lying on a bearskin rug in front of a fireplace. And of course, it goes where you think it will go, if two people are lying on a bearskin rug in front of a fireplace. But it's romantic, not explicit. The language is tame.
帕梅拉经常寄给杰西一些关于他们两人的故事以换取一点额外费用。在一个故事里，帕梅拉和杰西一起去野餐。另一个故事里，他像身披闪亮盔甲的骑士一样救了她。有一个故事写他们两人躺在壁炉前的熊皮地毯上。当然，如果两个人躺在壁炉前的熊皮地毯上，故事进展到你想的那一步也就顺理成章了。但它很浪漫，并不露骨。语言很温和。
The letter concludes, "I lay beside you and whispered good night, my sweet Darling. Let us drift away to paradise in our dreams and wake up together to a new and wonderful day. I kiss you gently and fall asleep in your arms." OK, obviously cheesy. Don Lowry was not a gifted writer, but he was a gifted manipulator. When I first heard about the story, I assumed the men who signed up for the letters from the angels must have been such easy marks, so naive. Who else would buy such absurd fantasies?
信的结尾写道：“我躺在你身边，低声说晚安，我甜蜜的亲爱的。让我们在梦中漂向天堂，一起醒来迎接新的一天。我轻轻地吻你，在你的怀抱中睡去。”好的，显然很俗气。唐·洛里不是有天赋的作家，但他是有天赋的操纵者。当我第一次听说这个故事时，我以为那些注册接收天使信件的男人一定很容易被骗，非常天真。还有谁会买账这种荒谬的幻想？
But then I read the dozens and dozens of letters that Pamela sent Jesse. He saved them in a large binder, each letter in its own plastic sleeve. And as I read the letters, I started to understand the power of the psychological tools Don used to hook men like Jesse. Most of the letters aren't epic fantasies. Most are about the minutiae of Pamela's life. She goes to the bank. She talks to co-workers. She tells Jesse her thoughts on televangelists.
但后来我读了帕梅拉写给杰西的几十封信。他把它们保存在一个大活页夹里，每封信都装在独立的塑料袋中。随着我阅读这些信件，我开始理解唐用来勾引像杰西这样男人的心理工具的力量。大多数信件都不是史诗般的幻想。大部分是关于帕梅拉生活中琐碎的事情。她去银行。她和同事聊天。她告诉杰西她对电视福音布道者的看法。
Over and over, Pamela tells Jesse how much he means to her. She praises him, encourages him. When you read the letters one after the other, like Jesse did day after day after day, it paints a picture that feels real. I felt the Pamela in the letters was a real person, and I knew Don was writing them.
帕梅拉反复告诉杰西他对自己意味着多少。她赞美他，鼓励他。当你像杰西那样日复一日地阅读这些信时，它描绘出了一种感觉很真实的画面。我感到信中的帕梅拉是一个真实的人，但我知道唐在写它们。
There were other tricks. In one letter, Pamela asked Jesse to keep a picture of hers nearby as he read her letters, so he would feel she was in the room with him. Jesse put up two photos of her on the wall. She once sent him a dime. In that letter, she told Jesse she had just had a strange day. Another driver bashed her car but didn't leave a note.
还有其他的诡计。在一封信中，帕梅拉要求杰西在读信时把她的照片放在旁边，这样他就会觉得她和他待在一个房间里。杰西把她的两张照片贴在墙上。她曾经寄给他一枚硬币。在那封信里，她告诉杰西她刚度过了奇怪的一天。另一名司机撞了她的车，但没留下字条。
Just when it looked like the day couldn't get any worse, she lost her purse. Depressed, Pamela spotted this very dime on the street. She picked it up, hoping it was a lucky charm. Later, a little boy showed up with her purse. A woman called and took responsibility for the car. Pamela told Jesse she was giving him her lucky dime. Here's Jesse reading from the end of that letter.
就在一天看起来不可能更糟的时候，她弄丢了钱包。沮丧中，帕梅拉在街上发现了这枚硬币。她捡起它，希望它是幸运符。后来，一个小男孩带着她的钱包出现了。一个女人打电话来承担了车祸责任。帕梅拉告诉杰西她要把她的幸运币送给他。这是杰西在读那封信的结尾。
"Keep this dime, Darling. Let it always remind you that good people can still come into your life and good things can still happen to you. And also think of this as a small token of my affection for you. If you hold it in your hand and squeeze it hard, you'll feel the warmth of my love coming out of it."
“留着这枚硬币，亲爱的。让它时刻提醒你，好人仍然会进入你的生活，好事仍然会发生在你身上。也把它看作我对你的一点点深情。如果你把它握在手里，紧紧挤压，你会感觉到我传递出来的爱的温暖。”
Did you actually do that, Jesse?
杰西，你真的那样做了吗？
Yes, I think I did do that and everything.
是的，我想我确实那样做了。
Like I said, Jesse's mother had recently died, and his dad had heart trouble. He spent a lot of time looking after him. He wrote letters to Pamela, confiding in her about his depression. She sent him heartfelt letters about bad relationships she'd had. And she told him about visiting her grandfather, who was suffering from dementia.
就像我说过的，杰西的母亲最近去世了，他的父亲有心脏病。他花了很多时间照顾父亲。他给帕梅拉写信，向她倾诉自己的抑郁。她寄给他感人至深的信，谈论她经历过的糟糕关系。她还告诉他关于看望患有痴呆症的祖父的事情。
That really took its toll on her, so I bonded with that, knowing that she was going through the same thing that I was. Me and her more or less bonded more than any other person I've ever talked to. It was like a beacon from outside, like if you were a ship out at sea and you were looking for lighthouse. Which they used that in the deal to look for the light and everything and guide yourself towards it, where you know that you'll have safe haven.
那真的让她很痛苦，所以我感同身受，因为我知道她经历着和我一样的事情。我和她建立的联系比我谈过的任何人都深。这就像来自外部的一座灯塔，就像如果你是一艘在海上航行的船，你在寻找灯塔。他们甚至在交易中使用了这种“寻找亮光并引导自己靠近它，在那里你会找到安全的港湾”的说法。
I'm not sure I'm exactly following you. Is this something from one of the letters, where they basically talk about the lighthouse?
我不确定我完全跟上你了。这是信里提到的东西吗？他们基本上谈论灯塔？
Yes, and in fact, I got a little wooden figure of a lighthouse that she sent to me at one time and everything, and said this beacon know that somebody is out there looking out for you and everything.
是的，事实上，我有一个小小的木制灯塔模型，是她有一次寄给我的，她说这个信标让你知道外面有人在看着你之类的。
If Jesse had wanted to see it, there were plenty of signs the letters were mass produced. They looked typed, but the paper doesn't have the indentations that come from typewriter keys. The signatures looked like they've been stamped or printed. All the specifics in the letters are about Pamela's life.
如果杰西想看出来，有很多迹象表明这些信件是批量生产的。它们看起来是用打字机打出来的，但纸张上没有打字机按键产生的凹痕。签名看起来像是盖章或印刷上去的。信中的所有细节都是关于帕梅拉的生活。
In the letters, did Pamela ever ask you how you were handling your mom's death?
在信里，帕梅拉有没有问过你你是怎么应对母亲去世的？
Not that I remember. No, I don't think so.
我不记得了。不，我觉得没有。
Did she ask how your dad's health was?
她有没有问过你父亲的身体状况？
Not that I remember at this time, no.
目前我也不记得了，没有。
In fact, when I read Pamela's letters to Jesse, she never mentions any of the things he's told her. When Pamela talks about Jesse's life, she switches into generalities. "I know you're sad. I know you're lonely. I know you're having a hard time." The only way the letters are personalized is that Jesse's name is sprinkled throughout, autofilled, like a madlib sheet. To Jesse, it didn't matter. He saw what he wanted to see.
事实上，当我读帕梅拉写给杰西的信时，她从未提到他告诉她的任何事情。当帕梅拉谈到杰西的生活时，她会切换到一般性的陈述。“我知道你很难过。我知道你很孤独。我知道你日子过得很艰难。”这些信件唯一的个性化之处就是杰西的名字被撒在各处，自动填充，就像“疯狂填词”游戏表一样。对杰西来说，这无关紧要。他看到了他想看到的东西。
At the time, I wasn't really fully absorbing all of that. I had a lot on my plate, in turmoil with everything that was going on. So I just read them and I took some like encouragement out of it.
当时，我并没有完全吸收所有这些。我有很多事情要处理，因为正在发生的一切而心烦意乱。所以我只是读了它们，并从中得到了一些鼓励。
Did you ever have doubts about what was going on as you were receiving the letters?
你在收到这些信件时，有没有怀疑过发生了什么？
Well, no, not at the time and everything. Like I said, I was glad to be getting letters from somebody, and even though you're paying money for that because you have blinders on and aren't really paying attention to all of that. Like I said, when you're not the best looking person in the world, that somebody out of the blue would write right to you and tell you things and build up your spirits and everything and stuff, because everybody looks at you and stuff, it's like the deal with the Hunchback of Notre Dame. You'll never find anybody that will care for you, but there at the end, he wound up making friends with the people that befriended him and everything.
嗯，没有，当时没有。就像我说过的，我很高兴能收到某人的信，即使你为此付了钱，因为你戴着眼罩，并没有真正注意到所有这些。就像我说的，当你不是世界上长得最好看的人时，有人突然给你写信，告诉你一些事情，提振你的精神，因为每个人都看你什么的，这就像《巴黎圣母院》里的驼背一样。你永远找不到会关心你的人，但最后，他最终和那些善待他的人成为了朋友。
At a certain point, Pamela became the thing that kept Jesse afloat when he had to work long hours, when he had to close his restaurant and rush his father to the hospital.
在某个时间点，当杰西不得不长时间工作、不得不关掉餐厅并把父亲送进医院时，帕梅拉成了让他支撑下去的精神支柱。
Yes, there was one thing that really touched me and everything. I was telling her I'm ready to give up and everything. And she just told me, get back on your feet and everything. So that really was a word of encouragement and everything.
是的，有一件事真的触动了我。我当时告诉她我准备放弃了。她只是告诉我，重新振作起来。所以那真的是一种鼓励。
As Don went on, he realized his members were hooked and he could take the fantasy further, much further. He invented an epic world for his angels, with a magical backstory and a fantastic future. Here's how it worked. The angels supposedly lived together in a retreat, hidden away from the world. Most were lost souls, escaping drugs and bad men. These were women who needed a steady hand and a strong shoulder.
随着唐的继续运作，他意识到他的会员们已经上钩了，他可以把幻想推得更远，远得多。他为他的天使们创造了一个史诗般的世界，有着神奇的背景故事和梦幻般的未来。它是这样运作的。这些天使据说一起生活在一个隐蔽的度假地。大多数是失落的灵魂，逃离毒品和坏男人。这些是需要稳重的手和坚实肩膀支撑的女性。
As he invented more angels, Don came up with interweaving backstories. Some angels were good, some bad. Angels helped one another, backstabbed each other. All the men who signed up to join the Lonely Hearts Club understood they were joining an organization of good hearted men who were devoted to taking care of the angels. The organization was known as the Call.
随着他编造出更多的天使，唐设计了相互交织的背景故事。有些天使是好的，有些是坏的。天使们互相帮助，也互相背叛。所有加入“孤独之心俱乐部”的男人都明白他们加入的是一个由善良男人组成的组织，致力于照顾这些天使。这个组织被称为“召唤”。
Don promised members of the Call that they would one day move with the angels to a valley paradise, into a giant building shaped like a naked woman lying down on the grass. This lady shaped building would house meeting rooms and auditoriums. The paradise was to be called Chonda-za. In exchange for their contributions, the members would have their needs looked after at Chonda-za, all their needs.
唐向“召唤”的成员承诺，有一天他们会和天使们搬到一个山谷天堂，进入一座巨大的建筑物，形状像一个躺在草地上的裸女。这座女性形状的建筑将容纳会议室和礼堂。这个天堂被称为“Chonda-za”。作为贡献的回报，成员们在Chonda-za的需求会得到照顾，他们所有的需求。
At the center of the entire fantasy was a matriarch, a saintly woman named Mother Maria. Maria collected and managed the money from the members, and she organized and disciplined the angels. She was said to have mystical powers and could revirginize fallen women. There were photos of Mother Maria. She was beautiful. Maria's photos were actually of a woman named Esther. She was Don's wife.
整个幻想的中心是一位女家长，一位叫玛丽亚母亲的圣洁女性。玛丽亚收集和管理来自成员的钱，她组织和管教天使。据说她有神秘的力量，可以治愈堕落女性。有玛丽亚母亲的照片。她很美。玛丽亚的照片其实是一个叫艾丝特的女人。她是唐的妻子。
Not all the members of the Call believed in Chonda-za. Jesse stuffed the letters describing Chonda-za in the back pocket of the binder. He figured it was just some wacky idea Pamela had and just ignored it. But there were other fish who found this Hoque tempting.
并非所有“召唤”的成员都相信Chonda-za。杰西把描述Chonda-za的信件塞进了活页夹的后口袋里。他以为那只是帕梅拉的一些古怪想法，就没理会。但还有其他鱼觉得这个骗局很诱人。
In my mind, I always held this area. I tried not to be convinced 100% about it. Surely, this was too good to be true.
在我心里，我一直保留这一点怀疑。我试着不去百分之百相信它。这肯定好得让人难以置信。
This is Ken Blanchard. He's a big gentle man and was another member of the Call for many years. He was single when he joined, and he was still single when I met him in 2012.
这是肯·布兰查德。他是一个大个子温和男人，也是“召唤”多年的成员。他加入时是单身，2012年我见到他时仍然单身。
What was the draw? What did you tell yourself when you said that this is too good to be true?
吸引力是什么？当你对自己说这好得令人难以置信时，你是怎么告诉自己的？
Well, I think with me it was the prospect of maybe at least having some sort of communication with some women, maybe my age, maybe a little bit too young for me, maybe even then. But it sounded like a neat idea to be on the leading edge of something like that. Oh geez, I don't know.
嗯，我想对我来说，前景至少是能和一些女性有某种交流，也许和我同龄，也许对我来说太年轻了一点点。但参与一些处于领先地位的事情听起来是个很酷的主意。哦天哪，我不知道。
Well--
嗯——
I don't know what else, how else to try to explain my part of it, or belief in it and everything. They got me hooked on what they were saying and everything. And I believed them, so--
我不知道还有什么办法来解释我参与其中，或者对此的信仰。他们让我对他们说的话上钩了。我相信他们，所以——
Don got hundreds of new sign-ups every year. Millions of dollars flowed back to Don's headquarters in Moline, Illinois. He bought himself expensive cars, a Rolls-Royce and a Mercedes. He bought his sons and Esther everything they wanted. He got a big office in downtown Moline and operated a print shop. He hired assistants, salespeople, and ghostwriters to expand his operation. By the mid-1980s, Don was writing love letters to more than 30,000 men.
唐每年都有数百名新成员签约。数百万美元流回了唐在伊利诺伊州莫林的总部。他为自己买了昂贵的汽车，劳斯莱斯和奔驰。他给他的儿子们和艾丝特买了他们想要的一切。他在莫林市中心得到了一个大办公室，并经营着一家印刷店。他雇佣了助理、销售员和代笔者来扩大业务。到20世纪80年代中期，唐正在为超过3万名男人写情书。
We had lawyers, doctors, professors, mechanics, bakers, you name it. All kinds of people were members. We even had a priest join the Call. Really.
我们有律师、医生、教授、技工、面包师，应有尽有。各种各样的人都是成员。我们甚至有一个神父加入了“召唤”。真的。
That's not a Catholic priest.
那不是天主教神父吧。
Yeah, a Catholic priest.
是的，天主教神父。
What was he hoping to get out of it?
他指望从中得到什么？
Who the hell knows? He was probably just bored.
鬼才知道。他大概只是无聊吧。
To exploit this growing market, Don constantly experimented with new schemes and products. He started selling cassette tapes, where the angels flirted with the men. He got into merch-- mugs, puzzles, commemorative coins, all with angels faces printed on them.
为了开发这个不断增长的市场，唐不断试验新的骗局和产品。他开始销售磁带，让天使们和男人们调情。他开始做周边——马克杯、拼图、纪念币，上面都印着天使的脸。
And we sent out a pillowcase with Angel Terry's face on it. And it said, now you can sleep with Angel Terry every night.
我们寄出了一个印着安吉尔·泰瑞脸的枕套。上面写着，现在你可以每晚和安吉尔·泰瑞睡觉了。
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑]
We did a lot of things like that.
我们做了很多这样的事。
The members weren't just sending in cash and checks. They were sending gifts. Ken sent Angel Vanessa a windbreaker. Others sent coats and shoes, even gardening equipment so the angels could grow vegetables at their secret retreat.
成员们不仅寄现金和支票。他们寄礼物。肯给安吉尔·凡妮莎寄了一件风衣。其他人寄大衣和鞋子，甚至园艺设备，这样天使们就可以在秘密度假地种植蔬菜。
Did you encourage them to send personal items?
你鼓励他们寄私人用品吗？
Oh God, no, no. I hated that. Here's a guy, his wife died. And she left all kinds of jewelry and dresses and so on. He put them in a big cardboard box and mailed it to us. What the hell are we going to do with it, huh?
天哪，不，不。我讨厌那个。有一个家伙，他妻子去世了。她留下了各种珠宝、裙子等等。他把它们装在一个大纸板箱里寄给了我们。我们到底能拿它们做什么？
Now, what you wanted, of course, was you wanted them to send a check.
那你当然想要的是他们寄支票。
Yeah, of course, or a money order, or cash, anything.
是的，当然，或者汇票，或者现金，什么都行。
Did you tell them not to do it?
你告诉他们不要这样做吗？
Very subtly. I didn't want to hurt their feelings. They thought they were doing a great thing for the angels by sending these clothes. I didn't want to hurt them.
很委婉地。我不想伤害他们的感情。他们以为自己通过寄这些衣服为天使做了件好事。我不想伤害他们。
My dad would brazenly just have sidewalk sales, lingerie, and gifts, and jewelry.
我爸爸会厚颜无耻地进行路边促销，卖内衣、礼物和珠宝。
This is Don's son, Rico Lowry.
这是唐的儿子，里科·洛里。
And my dad would brazenly just be selling the lingerie on racks in front of the print shop.
我爸爸会厚颜无耻地在印刷店门前的架子上卖这些内衣。
He would actually put up racks on the sidewalk in front of the print shop?
他真的在印刷店门前的人行道上放了架子？
Yep, yep. My dad had a very sarcastic and wicked sense of humor.
是的，是的。我爸爸有一种非常讽刺和邪恶的幽默感。
A local police officer told me men from all over the country started showing up in Moline, asking where they could find the angels. If they found their way to the print shop, Don called the cops on them. Dumbfounded police tried to explain to the men that there was no Angel Vanessa, no retreat, no Chonda-za. But occasionally, if Don was in the mood, he'd actually allow them to meet female employees whom he had asked to pose as angels in photos.
一位当地警官告诉我，来自全国各地的男人开始出现在莫林，询问在哪里能找到天使。如果他们找到了印刷店，唐就会报警抓他们。被搞糊涂的警察试图向这些男人解释，根本没有安吉尔·凡妮莎，没有度假地，没有Chonda-za。但偶尔，如果唐心情好，他真的会允许他们见见那些被他要求在照片中冒充天使的女员工。
In time, Don even set up events for his most loyal members to meet the angels. He called them gatherings. At a gathering in Chicago, an advice columnist offered dating suggestions. A comedian told jokes. Angels in yellow green dresses leapt around onstage in an interpretive dance.
后来，唐甚至为他最忠诚的成员举办了见天使的活动。他称之为“聚会”。在芝加哥的一次聚会上，一位咨询专栏作家提供了约会建议。一位喜剧演员讲了笑话。穿着黄绿色礼服的天使们在舞台上跳着现代舞。
Jesse went to the Moline gathering. He was excited to finally meet Pamela. She looked just like she did in her pictures. In fact, she was one of Don's employees and her name really was Pamela. She greeted Jesse warmly. But Jesse's excitement was tempered by the fact that there were a dozen other men at the gathering. Jesse was shocked to find that every man thought he was in a personal relationship with Pamela too. They crowded around her, vying for her attention.
杰西去了莫林的聚会。他很兴奋终于能见到帕梅拉了。她看起来和照片里一模一样。事实上，她是唐的一名员工，名字确实叫帕梅拉。她热情地问候了杰西。但杰西的兴奋被一个事实冲淡了，那就是聚会上还有十几个其他男人。杰西震惊地发现，每个男人都认为自己也和帕梅拉有着私人的关系。他们挤在她周围，争抢她的注意。
And then that's when it dawned on me. And I said, hey, this is not what I thought it would be or anything, that it was a rip-off. Well, that was like getting a kick in the stomach. It was upsetting and everything, wasting all that money and this and that and the other. And it wasn't what it was meant to be. It got you down to reality and stuff, so--
就在那时我明白了。我说，嘿，这根本不是我想的那样，这是个骗局。那感觉就像被人在胃上踹了一脚。这令人沮丧，浪费了那么多钱之类的。它不是原本该有的样子。这让你认清了现实，所以——
Jesse knew that Pamela liked music boxes, so he bought her an expensive one with a tiny record on it that played When the Saints Go Marching In . Pamela loved it. He says she stared at it and let the record play. It went on and on and on. The other men stood around them and looked at Jesse. They looked at Pamela, then back to Jesse. He liked that he was making them jealous.
杰西知道帕梅拉喜欢音乐盒，所以他买了一个昂贵的，上面有一个微小的唱片，播放着《当圣徒行军时》。帕梅拉很喜欢。他说她盯着它看，让唱片播放。它一直放啊放啊放。其他男人站在他们周围看着杰西。他们看着帕梅拉，然后又看向杰西。他喜欢自己让他们嫉妒的感觉。
Jesse didn't blame Pamela. He wasn't exactly sure how the scam worked, but he was sure that the woman standing before him was the same woman who wrote to him, that she was the one who had read his letters. The proof? Pamela's dog jumped into his lap.
杰西并没有责怪帕梅拉。他不确定这个骗局是怎么运作的，但他确信站在面前的这个女人就是写信给他的那个人，就是那个读过他信件的人。证据？帕梅拉的狗跳到了他的腿上。
She jumped on my lap twice and everything, and that really surprised Pamela and them. So I guess she smelled my scent on the letters I was writing to her and everything and stuff, so--
她两次跳到我腿上，这让帕梅拉他们都很惊讶。所以我猜她是闻到了我写信时的味道之类的，所以——
We got in touch with Pamela to see if she remembered any of this, but she declined to be interviewed on tape for the story. She did confirm that she hadn't written the letters. Jesse made friends with a couple of other men at the meeting, particularly two guys named Lenny and Al. They were all like strangers who had independently watched the same soap opera for many years.
我们联系了帕梅拉，想看看她是否还记得这些事，但她拒绝接受采访。她确实证实了她没写过这些信。杰西在聚会上和另外两个男人成了朋友，特别是两个叫莱尼和艾尔的人。他们就像一群多年来独立观看同一部肥皂剧的陌生人。
And we got to talking about it. I said, well, why did you write to this and everything? Instead of bonding with the girls, we ended up talking to each other and meeting new friends and talking about the troubles we had. Well, they were just like me and everything. So we stayed in correspondence. Like they said, they wrote me letters and they even called me at my restaurant to ask me how things were going and everything, and finding out, asking about my dad and everything, so that was encouraging to hear somebody calling to want to check on you and everything.
我们聊了起来。我说，好吧，你们为什么要写信给这个？与其和那些女孩建立联系，我们最终聊到了一起，结识了新朋友，谈论了我们遇到的麻烦。好吧，他们和我一样。所以我们保持通信。就像他们说的，他们给我写信，甚至打电话到我的餐厅问我情况怎么样，询问我父亲的情况，所以听到有人打电话来关心你，真的很令人鼓舞。
In other words, they asked about all the personal stuff Pamela never asked about. Lenny and Al stayed in touch until they died. What finally brought Don Lowry's scam to an end was a woman named Susan Rosseau. She was a model that Don had worked with. She'd gotten into a car crash and called Don for help. He showed up at the hospital with a photographer. They unbandaged her wounds and took pictures. They sent these to all the men who were corresponding with the angel Susan and asked them for help in paying her medical bills. But Don didn't give Susan the money. She went to the cops.
换句话说，他们询问了帕梅拉从未问过的所有私事。莱尼和艾尔一直保持联系直到他们去世。最终终结唐·洛里骗局的是一个叫苏珊·罗索的女人。她曾是唐合作过的一名模特。她出了车祸，打电话给唐求助。他带着摄影师出现在医院。他们揭开她的伤口绷带拍照。他们把这些照片寄给了所有与天使苏珊通信的男人，请求他们帮助支付医疗账单。但唐并没有把钱给苏珊。她报了警。
And she came to our office. She revealed the promises Mr. Lowry had made to her and broken. The return that Mr. Lowry received was staggering in terms of dollars and cents.
她来到我们的办公室。她揭露了洛里先生对她做出的承诺以及他的违背。洛里先生获得的回报在金钱方面是惊人的。
This is Lieutenant Kenneth Rexroth of the Moline police department. He'd been aware of Don Lowry for years. He turned away many men who would come to the police station in search of the angels. And he'd been looking for a way to lock Don up.
这是莫林警局的中尉肯尼斯·雷克斯罗斯。他多年来一直知道唐·洛里的存在。他拒绝了许多来到警察局寻找天使的男人。他一直在寻找一种方法把唐关起来。
He was very diabolical. He's a sinister person. I consider Mr. Lowry to be an evil man.
他非常邪恶。他是一个阴险的人。我认为洛里先生是一个邪恶的人。
But thanks to Susan Rosseau, the police finally had evidence to obtain subpoenas. They raided Don's print shop. They found out that some men sold everything in order to give their life savings to the angels. One man lived out of his car and forwarded his social security check to his angel. When the police got in touch with these guys, many of them realized for the first time that their treasured letters were written by a man.
但多亏了苏珊·罗索，警方终于有了传票证据。他们突袭了唐的印刷店。他们发现有些男人卖掉了一切，只为了把毕生积蓄献给天使。有一个人住在车里，把他所有的社保支票都寄给了他的天使。当警察联系上这些人时，他们中的许多人第一次意识到，他们珍视的信件竟然是由一个男人写的。
What I turned out to be angry about and more embarrassed about more than anything was the fact that he was even involved, that any man at all was even involved.
我感到生气和尴尬的，最主要的是这样一个事实：他竟然牵扯其中，任何男人竟然都牵扯其中。
Again, this is Ken Blanchard, who spent years receiving letters from Angel Vanessa.
同样，这是肯·布兰查德，他花了数年时间接收来自安吉尔·凡妮莎的信。
When I found out that these letters I'd been getting all these times and I thought it was some girl sharing something with me, well, then I find out it was him writing the darn thing, I thought, my God, what the hell am I getting into. But I can laugh about it now, but I think at the time I did have some feelings about that that weren't very charitable.
当我发现这些我一直收到的信件，我以为是一个女孩在和我分享，结果发现是他写这些该死的东西时，我想，天哪，我到底陷入了什么。但我现在可以笑对它了，但我认为当时我确实有些不那么慈悲的感受。
Don's lawyer said that if members believed the angels were real, that was on them. As Don told me many years later.
唐的律师说，如果成员们相信天使是真实的，那是他们自己的责任。正如唐许多年后告诉我的那样。
People believe what they want to believe. You cannot dissuade them. Most members believed the angels lived forever in a Never Never Land called the retreat. We told them that they live forever and they never grew old. Does that tell you anything? Huh?
人们相信他们想相信的东西。你无法劝阻他们。大多数成员相信天使永远生活在一个叫“度假地”的永无乡。我们告诉他们，她们永生，永不衰老。这能告诉你什么吗？嗯？
Well, you're surprised that they believed you?
嗯，你对他们相信你感到惊讶吗？
Yeah, yeah. And it helped them. I mean, it made them happy. So big deal.
是的，是的。而且这帮助了他们。我是说，这让他们快乐。所以大惊小怪什么。
Don and Pamela were charged with mail fraud, conspiracy, and money laundering. The press mobbed the trial. Don was shamed in the press, called a snake oil salesman in People Magazine . Which brings me back to what got me interested in the story in the first place, the thing that really surprised me. Many members flew from all over the country to show up at the courthouse in defense of the Call. Some stood outside with picket signs, defending the brotherhood.
唐和帕梅拉被控邮件欺诈、共谋和洗钱。媒体蜂拥而至参加审判。唐在媒体中蒙羞，在《人物》杂志中被称为“蛇油推销员”。这让我回到了让我最初对这个故事产生兴趣的原因，那件真正让我吃惊的事。许多成员从全国各地飞来，出现在法院外为“召唤”辩护。有些人站在外面举着标语，捍卫这个兄弟会。
Jesse and his friend Al were both there. As they waited outside the courtroom, Jesse saw Pamela come up. He rushed over to her.
杰西和他的朋友艾尔都在那里。当他们在法庭外等待时，杰西看到帕梅拉走了过来。他冲向她。
She was walking up, and I noticed that she was cold, so I took off my jacket and draped it over her shoulders, and we walked all the way up to the courthouse. I was like a security guard. And after she went indoors, I took my coat off and I backed off and everything.
她走过来时，我注意到她很冷，所以我脱下外套披在她肩上，我们就这样一直走到了法院。我就像个保安。在她进去之后，我脱下外套，退到后面。
Did she say anything to you at that point?
那时她对你说了什么吗？
No, not really.
没有，没说什么。
Members testified on the stand and said the Call had been a critical, beautiful part of their lives. One man said letters from the angel saved him from alcoholism and thoughts of suicide. Jesse testified too. This is him reading a court transcript of what he said on the stand.
成员们在证人席上作证说，“召唤”是他们生命中关键、美好的一部分。一个男人说，来自天使的信救了他，使他摆脱了酗酒和自杀倾向。杰西也作证了。这是他在读证人席上所说内容的法庭记录。
Well, it gave you, like I said, inspiration to continue no matter what the circumstances that you were going through, that if you persevered, you could make it.
好吧，它给了你，就像我说过的，无论经历什么情况都要坚持下去的灵感，如果你坚持不懈，你就能成功。
Do you remember saying this at the trial?
你记得在审判时说过这些吗？
Yes, I do.
是的，我记得。
Would you say that you still stand by what you said at trial?
你还会说你依然坚持你在审判时所说的吗？
Yes.
是的。
So here's the thing, Jesse, Don Lowry lied to you and sent you letters on behalf of someone else for many years. And you formed an emotional connection with this woman who was writing to you, when at the same time you showed up at trial to essentially defend Don Lowry. And I'm trying to understand how and why you did that.
所以重点是，杰西，唐·洛里欺骗了你，多年来以他人的名义给你写信。你和一个给你写信的女人建立了情感联系，而与此同时你出现在法庭上本质上是在为唐·洛里辩护。我想弄明白你是如何以及为什么那样做的。
Well, like I said before, it wasn't actually defending him, but it was actually Pamela that was the one that we were all turned our attention to help, and that meant helping Don also and everything.
嗯，就像我之前说的，这并不是在为他辩护，实际上帕梅拉才是我们所有人注意力转向去帮助的对象，那意味着也要帮助唐。
I understand that Don was really the mastermind of the operation. But when she showed up at these meetings and she presented herself as the same Pamela who was the Pamela in the letters, wasn't she lying to you?
我明白唐确实是这一行动的幕后操纵者。但当她出现在这些聚会上，并表现得和信里的帕梅拉是同一个帕梅拉时，她不是在欺骗你吗？
Well, I guess you could think about that that way, yes.
嗯，我想你可以那样想，是的。
Did you ever think about it that way?
你有想过那是欺骗吗？
No, not until now and everything, when all of this has been rebrought out and everything.
没有，直到现在，当所有这些被重新提起的时候，才开始想。
Don and Pamela were both found guilty. Pamela served two years in prison. Don was in prison for 10 years. When I met Don, I asked him whether he felt he did anything wrong.
唐和帕梅拉都被判有罪。帕梅拉在监狱里服刑两年。唐入狱10年。当我见到唐时，我问他是否觉得他做了什么错事。
I think I did something very wrong. I suppose I made it a little bit too real. I did. I made it too real.
我想我确实做了非常错误的事。我想我把它做得太真实了。我做到了。我把它做得太真实了。
Jesse lives alone now with his dog Chewbacca. He's in his 60s and is still single. He's had some complications from diabetes recently, and had parts of his foot amputated. It hasn't been easy. My producer, Stephanie Foo, visited him at his house in Texas.
杰西现在和他的狗“楚巴卡”独自生活。他60多岁，仍然单身。他最近患有糖尿病的一些并发症，部分脚部被截肢。这并不容易。我的制片人，斯蒂芬妮·傅，去他在德克萨斯州的家中看望了他。
I was in the hospital after my amputation, running around on my knee scooter. I said, you can still do this. Keep going and everything, so-- and I remember those words she told me. "Get on your feet." So I do that and everything and keep going.
我截肢后还在医院里，踩着膝盖滑板车到处跑。我说，你还是能做到的。继续前进，所以——我记得她告诉我的那些话。“重新振作起来。”所以我确实那样做了，并坚持下去。
Wow. Even now, even today?
哇。即使现在，即使今天？
Even today and everything and stuff so.
即使今天，我还在坚持。
But basically, that line, "Get on your feet," it doesn't really matter who wrote it?
但是基本上，那句“重新振作起来”，是谁写的真的重要吗？
No. You think back, but it brings back fond memories of way back when, and you could be in your 100s and everything or older and I hope to have this on my mind on down the line and everything and stuff so.
不。你回想一下，它带回了很久以前的美好回忆，你可能已经100岁甚至更老了，我希望在以后的人生路上能一直记住这一点。
Jesse still has the little wooden lighthouse Pamela sent him. It's on his dresser in his bedroom. And he still has two photos of Pamela in his den, one on the wall, one on his desk. In one, she's sitting in an office chair, hands in her lap, not glamorous, or sexy, or anything. Jesse says she's just sitting there, being herself. It's just a little something to say "I made a friend."
杰西依然保留着帕梅拉寄给他的那个木制小灯塔。它在他卧室的梳妆台上。而且他在书房里依然有两张帕梅拉的照片，一张在墙上，一张在书桌上。其中一张，她坐在办公椅上，双手放在腿上，并不迷人，也不性感。杰西说她只是坐在那里，做她自己。这只是一个小东西，用来证明“我交了一个朋友”。
Shankar Vedantam, he's NPR's social science correspondent and host of a brand new podcast called Hidden Brain about the world of unconscious bias in human behavior. You might check out especially episode three about poker and women. That's Hidden Brain episode 3, wherever you get your podcasts.
尚卡尔·维丹坦，他是NPR的社会科学记者，也是一个关于人类行为中无意识偏见世界的全新播客《隐藏的大脑》的主持人。你可以特别看看关于扑克和女性的第三集。那就是《隐藏的大脑》第三集，在任何你收听播客的地方都能找到。
Coming up, romantic feelings popping up aggressively, undeniably in Times Square, on the 405 in Los Angeles. They are everywhere. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，浪漫的感觉积极地、不可否认地在时代广场、洛杉矶的405公路上涌现。它们无处不在。节目稍后继续，来自芝加哥公共广播电台。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, The Heart Wants What It Wants. What happens when you find that whether you like it or not, you're having feelings, big feelings for somebody who is giving you signs that it really might not work out? We first broadcast this show a year ago. We have arrived at Act 2 of our program, Act 2, My Love is Blue.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目主题是《心之所向》。当你发现无论你是否喜欢，你对一个明明显示出可能不会有结果的人有着强烈的情感时，会发生什么？我们一年前首次播放了这个节目。我们现在来到节目的第二幕，《我的爱是忧郁的》。
Elsa Waithe is a stand up comedian, young, moved to New York City not that long ago. Two years ago, after the policeman who shot Michael Brown was not indicted for killing him, she felt like, OK, that is not right. And she decided to join the protesters who were out demonstrating about the decision and about police behavior. And at her very first protest, this thing happened she did not expect. She got a very inconvenient crush on somebody she had no desire to have a crush on. And of course, as we have heard this hour, that is something you cannot control.
埃尔莎·怀斯是一位脱口秀喜剧演员，年轻，搬到纽约没多久。两年前，在枪杀迈克尔·布朗的警察因杀人未被起诉后，她觉得，好吧，这不对。她决定加入那些抗议这个决定和警察行为的示威者行列。在她的第一次抗议活动中，发生了一件她没预料到的事。她对一个她毫无兴趣的人产生了一种非常麻烦的迷恋。当然，就像我们这一个小时里听到的，这是你无法控制的事情。
She talked about this on stage in a storytelling show about crushes. We have a recording from that show that is a little janky but it is totally audible with, as you will hear, a very enthusiastic audience. If you're listening online or to the podcast of our program, I want to say before we start, we have unbeeped a few curse words here in this online version of the program. If you prefer the beeped version of our show, maybe you're listening with little kids, you can get that it's thisamericanlife.org. Anyway, here's Elsa.
她在舞台上的一个关于迷恋的故事讲述秀上谈到了这件事。我们有那个秀的录音，虽然有点杂音，但完全听得清，而且正如你将听到的，观众非常热情。如果你在线收听或收听本节目的播客，我想在开始前说明，我们在节目的这个在线版本中没有消音掉一些脏话。如果你更喜欢有消音的版本，也许你和小孩一起收听，可以在thisamericanlife.org获取。无论如何，这是埃尔莎。
And so now once we get to Times Square, we've met up with other groups. And at this point, it's massive. So we spread across the intersection, and we all sit down. And sure enough, the riot cops step up. And the riot police all have the face masks, the face guards. And a part of me is thinking this is very intimidating. And you can't see anybody's face. And they're really big, and it's just one stormtrooper sort of thing of very scary police officers.
所以现在我们到了时代广场，我们和其他团体汇合了。此时，人群规模巨大。所以我们散布在十字路口，然后大家都坐下了。果不其然，防暴警察上前了。所有的防暴警察都戴着面罩、防护面罩。我的一部分心想，这非常具有威慑力。你看不到任何人的脸。他们真的很高大，简直就是一排非常可怕的警察风暴兵。
And at this point, you guys, I'm really nervous. I'm really scared because they've given a dispersal warning and people are getting flustered and people are starting to leave. And those of us who are sitting down, it's dwindled. There's also lots of cameras here, so I've made my stand. I don't want to get up, OK?
而且此时，各位，我真的很紧张。我真的很害怕，因为他们发出了疏散警告，人们开始变得慌乱，人们开始离开。而我们这些坐着的人，人数减少了。这里还有很多摄像机，所以我已经表明了立场。我不想起来，好吗？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
People are going to see that. And I'm just trying to find a zen place. I'm just trying to look around and just find something to focus on, and really all I'm seeing is my reflection in all of these face masks, until I get to one officer, who has not put her face mask down, you guys. And it was just the most angelic face.
人们会看到的。我只是试图找一个禅定的地方。我只是试图四处看，找点东西专注，但我看到的只是我在所有这些面罩上的倒影，直到我看到一个警察，她还没有放下她的面罩，各位。那是一张最天使般的脸。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
It was very delicate inside of this. And it almost didn't seem like she even wanted to be there. I was transfixed. And the sergeant, he says line up. And I realize that they're lining up in front of who they are going to arrest, and she's lined up with me.
在这下面非常精致。而且看起来她甚至都不想待在那里。我惊呆了。中士说排队。我意识到他们正在排在他们要逮捕的人前面，而她排在我的前面。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And he gives one more dispersal warning. He says you have 30 seconds to get out of the street. You were obstructing traffic. If you do not get out of the street, you are subject to arrest. And I says, well, her?
他又发出了一个疏散警告。他说你们有30秒离开街道。你们阻碍了交通。如果不离开街道，你们将被逮捕。我心想，诶，她？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
The Sergeant gets one the megaphone and he says, OK, that's it. Whoever's here, round them up. And so she leans in and she says, you're going to have to come with me. And I realize I'm being filmed. There's lots of cameras. Flashbulbs are going off everywhere. And so I wanted to be really thug and gangster about it, you know what I'm saying? You know? I was like, in my mind, I said, "Yeah, you're going have to pick me up!" But I think what actually came out and was like, "Yeah, OK."
中士拿着扩音器说，好了，就这样。不管谁在这里，把他们围起来。所以她靠过来对我说，你得跟我走。我意识到我被拍摄了。有很多摄像机。闪光灯到处在闪。所以我想表现得很强悍、像个黑帮一样，你懂我的意思吗？你知道吗？我在心里想，“好吧，你得抬我走！”但我认为实际说出来的是，“好的，行。”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
She picks me up, and she turns me around. And she goes to put the zip ties, the flex cuffs on me. And it was really-- she put them on really tight, you guys. And I wanted to be upset, but I kind of liked it. I don't know.
她把我抬起来，把我转过去。她去给我戴上塑料手铐，那种灵活的手铐。而且真的——各位，她戴得非常紧。我本想生气，但我竟然有点喜欢。我不知道。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And here's the thing, you guys. I was part of the first 10 people to be arrested in New York City in conjunction with these non-indictments. They were calling us the Times Square 10. My picture was everywhere. In the morning, when I woke up, it was on CNN. It was on Yahoo News. And so all my friends back home, they've seen these pictures, and everyone's like, wow, you look really calm amongst all this chaos and--
各位，重点来了。我是纽约市因这些非起诉决定而被逮捕的前10人之一。他们叫我们“时代广场十人组”。我的照片到处都是。早上醒来时，它在CNN上。它在雅虎新闻上。所以我家乡所有的朋友都看到了这些照片，每个人都说，哇，你在这种混乱中看起来真的很冷静，而且——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
What was going through your mind?
你当时在想什么？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I wanted to tell people something really poignant, you know? I was thinking about civil rights and I was thinking about Dr. King. And I wanted to tell you that it was all those things. But really it was just like, "Holy shit, there's a lot of cameras! Her hands are soft."
我本想告诉人们一些非常深刻的东西，你知道吗？我当时在想公民权利，在想马丁·路德·金博士。我本想告诉你们那是所有那些事情。但实际上只是像，“天哪，这里有好多摄像机！她的手真软。”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Gosh. So they load us into the back of the paddy-wagon. Unfortunately, she does not ride with us. But when we get to the precinct now, I'm reunited with my arresting officer, because they have to take you through the booking process, OK? And so then they take your mugshot. Now, I'm ready for this. All the excitement from getting arrested has dissipated. Here's the real shit. I'm getting processed now, but you're partnered up with who arrested you.
天哪。所以他们把我们装进囚车后部。遗憾的是，她没有和我们一起乘车。但当我们到达警局时，我和我的逮捕警察重逢了，因为他们必须带你完成预审程序，好吗？然后他们拍了你的入案照片。现在，我准备好了。被逮捕的所有兴奋感都消散了。这才是正事。我现在正在被处理，但你和你逮捕你的人配对在一起。
So I get her name now. This is Officer Laura. All right. So now I have her name and this is great. So she's taking me through the fingerprinting process, and they have to take your hand. They do it for you. They take your hand. And she's holding my hand.
所以我现在知道了她的名字。这是劳拉警官。好了。所以现在我知道她的名字了，这太棒了。她带我完成了指纹识别过程，他们必须握住你的手。他们为你做。他们握住你的手。她握着我的手。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And pressing my fingers into the ink, and now we're making a finger picture and it's gorgeous. This is our first piece of artwork together!
把我的手指按在墨水里，现在我们在制作指纹照片，真是太美了。这是我们一起创作的第一件艺术品！
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And now it was mugshot time, you guys. It was time for the mugshot. And I am determined. I am going to take a gangster mugshot, OK? I know nothing about this says gangster, but I'm going to thug up and take this mugshot, right? So we take it from the front. Boom. Take it from the side, boom. And then, you guys, surprise, surprise, your arresting officer gets in the picture with you!
现在是入案照片时间了，各位。该拍入案照片了。我下定决心。我要拍一张黑帮式的入案照片，好吗？我知道这一切看起来一点都不像黑帮，但我会装出强硬的样子拍这张照片，对吧？所以我们正面拍一张。砰。侧面拍一张，砰。然后，各位，惊喜，惊喜，你的逮捕警察和你一起入镜！
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And we get to take a picture together! I was so excited! I was so strong in the first two pictures, and then she gets in for the third, and I was so amped I threw a thumb up.
我们竟然可以一起拍张照！我太兴奋了！前两张照片我表现得那么强悍，然后她进来拍第三张，我太激动了，我竖起了一个大拇指。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
She didn't find that amusing. She slapped my hand. She's like, no gang signs! Can I get a copy of this for Facebook? No one's going to believe me! All right, so that's where all the fun stopped, you guys. They put me in the cell. I was in for 8 and 1/2 hours. But I left in the morning. I wasn't tired. I wasn't upset. I just had butterflies, cherubs, rainbows, unicorns. I wonder if I'll ever see her again. You know?
她觉得这并不好笑。她打了我的手。她说，不许做黑帮手势！我可以要一张这个发到Facebook上吗？没人会相信我！好了，玩闹到此为止了，各位。他们把我关进牢房。我待了8个半小时。但我早上就出去了。我不累。我不难过。我只是感到心里小鹿乱撞，充满了天使、彩虹、独角兽。我不知道我是否还会再见到她。你懂吗？
But I finally got the gumption to go back out. I'm not going to let this silence me. I'm not going to let this scare me. And I had some down time. I'm going to go back out. And so I went back out, no friends, nobody to tell anybody I was back out. Went back to Times Square and I was out there taking laps around Times Square with signs, waiting for the crowd to get bigger. And you guys, I see what appears to be Officer Laura.
但我终于鼓起勇气又回去了。我不会让这件事让我沉默。我不会让这件事吓倒我。我有了一些空闲时间。我要回去。所以我又回去了，没有朋友，没人告诉任何人我又回去了。回到时代广场，我在那里围着时代广场绕圈，拿着牌子，等着人群变大。然后各位，我看到了看起来像是劳拉警官的人。
And you've got to understand, I'm with some really anti-police people. So you really can't say shit to the cops, right? But I got [INAUDIBLE]. And I was like, "Officer Laura." And she turned around and it was her. And I couldn't contain my excitement. I was like, "Oh my God, it's so good to see you!"
而且你必须明白，我和一些非常反警察的人在一起。所以你真的不能对警察说任何屁话，对吧？但我[听不清]。我说，“劳拉警官。”她转过身来，真的是她。我无法抑制我的兴奋。我说，“天哪，见到你真好！”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And I gave her a hug.
然后我给了她一个拥抱。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Which didn't win me points from anybody. Because the protesters weren't happy and neither were the police. And Officer Laura didn't remember me, you guys.
这并没有为我赢得任何人的分数。因为抗议者们不高兴，警察们也不高兴。而劳拉警官根本不记得我，各位。
[MOANING]
[呻吟]
So fuck the police. All right.
所以，去他妈的警察。好吧。
Elsa Waithe, she hosts a monthly comedy night in New York called Affirmative Laughter. On Twitter, she is elsajustelsa. She has recorded a monthly storytelling event called Tell at the Bureau of General Service Queer Division on 13th Street.
埃尔莎·怀斯，她在纽约主持一个名为“肯定笑声”的月度喜剧之夜。在Twitter上，她是elsajustelsa。她在第13街的“普通服务酷儿部门局”录制了一个名为“讲述”的月度故事讲述活动。
Act 3, Unbreak My Heart. So this last story starts in exactly the way you would expect if you were even half paying attention to today's program.
第三幕，治愈我的心。所以这个最后一个故事开始的方式和你预想的一模一样，如果你哪怕只关注了一半今天的节目。
I definitely 100% thought he was the one.
我绝对百分之百地认为他是那个对的人。
That's Julia. A few years back, when she was in her 20s, she dated this guy who lived in England. She was in Los Angeles. She loved thinking about marrying him and moving to England and raising little babies with British accents who'd call her mummy. And then one day, she was at work.
那是茱莉亚。几年前，当她20多岁时，她和一个住在英国的男人约会。她在洛杉矶。她喜欢想将来嫁给他，搬到英国，养着带英国口音的孩子，叫她“木乃伊”。然后有一天，她在工作。
And we were on Skype. Not the video Skype, but the chat Skype, just typing to each other, like instant messenger.
我们在Skype上。不是视频Skype，而是文字Skype，只是互相打字，就像即时通讯。
And he dumped her, not even on video. He text dumped her.
然后他甩了她，甚至没用视频。他发短信甩了她。
And it really took me by surprise. He wrote, "This isn't working for me." And I thought he meant his computer or something. I had no idea he was talking about our entire relationship.
这真的让我措手不及。他写道，“这对我来说行不通。”我以为他是在说他的电脑什么的。我根本不知道他在说我们的整段关系。
Well, the wording leaves it vague, to be fair. The wording is very vague.
嗯，平心而论，这个说法很模糊。措辞非常模糊。
Yeah, I agree.
是的，我同意。
She couldn't concentrate on work anymore. Her life was wrecked. No more babies calling her mummy in the future. And as she drove home, sitting in traffic--
她没法集中精力工作了。她的生活毁了。未来再也没有孩子叫她“木乃伊”了。当她开车回家时，坐在车流中——
I called 1-800-Expedia, and I bought a one way ticket to England that left in six hours.
我拨打了1-800-Expedia，买了一张六小时后出发去英国的单程机票。
Maybe you should explain your thinking here.
也许你该解释一下你的想法。
I really thought, OK I'm going to make this big grand gesture. I'm a big rom com fan. And I felt like this was my rom com moment in life. What would Bridget Jones do? You know what she would do? She would go to England right away. So that was the plan. I thought I'd show up at his house. It would be a surprise. And he'll see me and our eyes will lock. And if he sees me, he'll remember that we're perfect for each other and we should get married.
我真的想，好吧，我要做一个盛大的姿态。我是个浪漫喜剧大粉丝。我觉得这就是我人生中的浪漫喜剧时刻。布里吉特·琼斯会怎么做？你知道她会做什么吗？她会立刻去英国。所以这就是计划。我想我会出现在他家门口。那会是个惊喜。他会看到我，我们的目光会锁定。如果他看到我，他会记得我们是天造地设的一对，我们应该结婚。
So packs a bag. Overpacks, actually, because who knows how long she'll be staying. Maybe the rest of her life? Lands in England, gets off the plane, then it hits her.
所以她打包了一个包。其实是超额打包了，因为谁知道她会待多久？也许余生？降落在英国，下飞机，然后她突然意识到。
As I'm in the customs line, I start like crying and a little bit freaking out, what am I doing? And I think that was the first time I started thinking, what if it doesn't go as they think that it'll go? You know?
当我排在海关队里时，我开始哭泣，有点崩溃，我在做什么？我认为这是我第一次开始想，如果事情不像我想象的那样发展怎么办？你懂吗？
Yeah.
是的。
When he sees me, he won't say you're the one.
当他看到我时，他不会说你是那个对的人。
Yeah.
是的。
So I started crying. And I approach-- I get to the front and I approached this customs agent, who was this adorable little British guy. He was maybe 20.
所以我开始哭了。然后我走到——我走到前面，接近了这个海关官员，一个可爱的英国小个子。他大概20岁。
He asks her, how long are you going to be in the country? Standard question. But this sets off a huge cry, because of course that is the biggest question in her whole life at this moment. The answer depends entirely on the boyfriend. She spills the whole story to the British customs agent.
他问她，你要在这个国家待多久？标准问题。但这引发了一场巨大的痛哭，因为当然这是她此时此刻人生中最大的问题。答案完全取决于那个男朋友。她向英国海关官员倾诉了整个故事。
The whole story, the whole plan. My boyfriend dumped me on Skype yesterday. I bought a one way ticket to England. I'm going to surprise him. And I told him, you know, but he's the one. He just forgets I'm the one. And I looked at him. I'm like, "Is that crazy?"
整个故事，整个计划。我男朋友昨天在Skype上甩了我。我买了一张去英国的单程机票。我要给他个惊喜。我告诉他，你知道，但他才是那个对的人。他只是忘记了我是那个对的人。我看着他。我问：“那是不是很疯狂？”
And I swear to you, Ira, he looked me straight in the eye, and with this adorable little British accent, he says, "You got to do what you got to do for love."
我向你发誓，艾拉，他直视我的眼睛，用那种可爱的英国口音说，“为了爱，你必须做你必须做的事。”
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑]
Which I thought was like, "Yeah, he's right!" I mean, come on. That's straight out of a romantic comedy, right? And I really thought at that moment, I am doing what I got to do for love. That's what I'm doing right now!
我当时想，“对，他是对的！”我是说，拜托。那是直接出自浪漫喜剧，对吧？那一刻我真的认为，我正在做我必须为了爱做的事。我就是在那时做的！
She did not end up with the guy. When he sees her, he does not propose. He doesn't know. You are not the one. She flies home the next morning.
她没能和那个男人在一起。当他看到她时，他没有求婚。他不知道。你不是那个对的人。她第二天早上飞回了家。
Can I ask you when you look back on this, the thing that the British customs agents said to you, what was the line again?
能问你当你回首往事时，那个英国海关官员对你说的话吗，那句话是怎么说的？
He said, "You got to do what you got to do for love."
他说，“为了爱，你必须做你必须做的事。”
Do you think he's right, in retrospect?
回顾过去，你认为他是对的吗？
I think, yeah. You know, I think he's right. And I'm glad I did what I thought I had to do for love. Because it really put the nail in the coffin on that relationship.
我认为，是的。你知道，我认为他是对的。而且我很高兴我做了我认为为了爱必须做的事。因为它真的给那段关系钉上了棺材板。
Wait, you think you did the right thing even though you also think, with the distance of years, that it was crazy?
等等，你认为你做了正确的事，尽管你也认为，从几年的距离来看，那是疯狂的？
It was crazy. Don't get me wrong. But if I hadn't done all of this, I don't know. It would feel a little open ended.
那是疯狂的。别误会我。但如果我没做所有这一切，我不知道。那会感觉有点不了了之。
It's so interesting that this is what you're saying to me. Because we began this week's show with a 76-year-old man who on Sunday is flying across the country to tell this woman that he has feelings for her, and to see if she has feelings for him. And he knows, I think, in the back of his mind, that it's probably doomed, and he can't stop himself.
你对我说的这番话真有意思。因为我们本周节目的开头提到了一位76岁的老人，他周日要飞越大半个国家去告诉那个女人他有感觉，并看看她是否有感觉。我认为他心里可能知道，那很可能注定失败，但他无法阻止自己。
Well, he's got to do it, though, right? He's got to do what he's got to do for love, Ira.
嗯，但他必须做，对吧？他必须做为了爱必须做的事，艾拉。
No, I agree. I think you're saying it as a little bit of a joke, but I think he actually does. I think that that's the truth.
不，我同意。我觉得你是在开玩笑，但我认为他确实必须这样做。我认为那是事实。
Yeah, yeah.
是的，是的。
If you had any advice for him, what would you say to him, if you could send a message to him right now?
如果你对他有什么建议，如果现在能给他传个话，你会说什么？
It's funny, because I wouldn't even say it like you don't want to prepare yourself for the worst, because that's just going into it having a bad attitude. I think the way I went into it, going into it really thinking this is going to happen, this is my life and this is how it works out, I think that's the best way to go into it. And then just deal with whatever fallout happens.
很有趣，因为我甚至不会像“你不想为最坏的情况做准备”那样说，因为那只是带着坏态度去面对。我认为我当时的做法——带着认为这会发生的想法去，认为这就是我的生活，这就是它如何发展——我认为那是最好的处理方式。然后只管应对发生的任何后果。
Julia Lillis, she now has a baby who calls her mommy, and a second one on the way, and a husband who does not have a British accent but apparently has other good qualities to compensate.
茱莉亚·莉莉丝，她现在有一个叫她“木乃伊”的宝宝，第二个也在路上，还有一个没有英国口音但显然有其他优点可以补偿的丈夫。
Our program was produced todayy by Zoe Chace, Robyn Semien and me with Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer for this show is Brian Reed. Our technical director is Matt Tierney. Production help from Emmanuel Dzotsi. Our staff includes Elise Bergerson, Emily Condon, Kimberly Henderson, and Seth Lind.
我们今天的节目由佐伊·蔡斯、罗宾·塞米恩和我制作，还有肖恩·科尔、尼尔·德拉明、斯蒂芬妮·傅、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。我们节目的高级制片人是布莱恩·里德。我们的技术总监是马特·蒂尔尼。制作协助来自伊曼纽尔·佐齐。我们的工作人员包括埃莉斯·伯格森、艾米莉·康顿、金伯利·亨德森和塞思·林德。
Research help today from Christopher Swetala and Michelle Harris. Music help today from Damian Graef and Rob Geddis. Special thanks today to Nancy Bermeo, Michael Dodge Weiskopf, Paul Rest, Carol McGuirk Allison, Maggie Penman, Anne Gudenkauf, Jefferson Bites.
今天的研究协助来自克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉和米歇尔·哈里斯。今天的音乐协助来自达米安·格雷夫和罗伯·格迪斯。今天的特别感谢来自南希·贝尔梅奥、迈克尔·道奇·韦斯科普夫、保罗·雷斯特、卡罗尔·麦奎克·艾利森、玛吉·彭曼、安妮·古登考夫、杰斐逊·比特斯。
This show first aired a year ago. The 76-year-old man that you heard at the beginning of the program did not get a yes from the woman that he flew across the country for. He has moved on. He says he has no regrets. He's glad he tried. Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our programs co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he got a new puppy, puts him to sleep every night with these words.
这个节目一年前首次播出。你在节目开头听到的那位76岁的老人，并没有从他飞越全国去找的那位女性那里得到肯定的答复。他已经向前看了。他说他没有任何遗憾。他很高兴自己尝试过。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交易所PRX发送给公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人托瑞·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，他养了一只新小狗，每天晚上都会用这些话哄它睡觉。
Good night, my sweet Darling. Let us drift away to paradise in our dreams and wake up together to a new and wonderful day. I kiss you gently and fall asleep in your arms.
晚安，我甜蜜的亲爱的。让我们在梦中漂向天堂，一起醒来迎接新的一天。我轻轻地吻你，在你的怀抱中睡去。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。